millones de papeletas se distribuyeron
el sábado en ecuador para que los
votantes puedan acudir a las urnas del
domingo y elegir presidente en segunda
vuelta entre andrés araud y guillermo
lasso la primera vuelta estuvo manchada
por denuncias de fraude del movimiento
indígena la estrecha vigilancia del
proceso electoral por parte de las
autoridades y el ejército trata de
evitar que las denuncias se repitan todo
nuestro contingente todos nuestros
funcionarios empleados están listos los
miembros de junta receptora del voto han
sido capacitados nuevamente se les están
entregando en cada paquete electoral va
a un flujograma de las actividades que
tienen que cumplir para reforzar lo de
la primera vuelta en perú el material
electoral también se distribuyó a todos
los puntos de votación para acoger a los
más de 25 millones de ciudadanos
llamados a votar en las presidenciales
que están saliendo de este espacio 200
camiones acompañados también de 200
patrulleros
[Música]
estamos movilizando 450 toneladas
incluye material electoral y material
también vinculado a la protección y la
seguridad de los miembros de mesa frente
al virus en la primera vuelta en perú se
da por descontado que ninguno de los 18
candidatos superará el 50 por ciento de
los votos necesarios para acceder a la
presidencia directamente el país se
encuentra inmerso en un fuerte repunte
de contagios de kobe 19 por ejemplo el
periodo de votación se extendió a 12
horas para evitar aglomeraciones con
estas elecciones pero trata de resolver
la crisis política que lo ha llevado a
tener cuatro presidentes en cinco años